bienvenue sur l'île de burk pour le
quatrième Ronin des courses de dragons, je suis
mongo et ici pidley, bonjour, maintenant
rencontrons d'abord nos coureurs et leurs dragons, ce sont
les Twins Ruffnut et Toughnut
et Bel dans Lane T, c'est comme chevauchant
Stormfly puis dans  Voie trois, c'est Bish
Leg chevauchant une bûche de viande et dans la voie quatre,
c'est Scotet chevauchant H Fang, puis les
Sheep Riders sont
partis. Je ne voudrais pas être ce
type, des cuisses de poisson et une bûche de viande qui cherchent à
marquer un but intercepté par Stlo, c'est parti
bébé oh viens.  sur blf, ça commence à puer par
ici, faisons exploser cet endroit, éructez,
c'est ce qu'on appelle une flamme, un superbe coup de feu
après Twins et maintenant conscient de nos
sponsors, la course d'aujourd'hui vous est présentée
en partie par Go Fire et Insurance lorsque
votre dragon allume un feu, vous êtes  entre de bonnes
mains avec goba maintenant retour au
jeu ici bin pour positionner le
mouton noir on peut encore gagner ce Stormfly
allons gabber qui est sur le terrain
maintenant avec le mouton noir bon
vol vers le haut va la Wild Card vers le haut vers le haut vers le
haut  là-haut, elle vaut 10 points, c'est
suffisant pour gagner oh, sa jambe l'accroche, voilà,
tu y vas, chérie, la mienne en vaut 10 ouais le
mouton noir, personne ne peut m'arrêter maintenant,
sauf moi qui arrive par derrière oh
ça gâche tout pas de mouton pas de
gloire, parle de voler  voyons
ça dans le replay alors
aucun F TR ne va pour la victoire excusez-moi
starf oh gentil Doge par asri mais nous le
ferons découvrir dans Comment dresser votre
dragon
aussi